ty alors premier premier enjeu et c'est
ce que je vous disais tout à l'heure
nous avons un indicateur très important
qui n'est pas celui des morts qui n'est
pas celui des cas confirmés mais qui est
bien celui des arrivées en milieu
hospitalier qui reflète des
contaminations survenu environ 15 jours
avant vous avez été contaminés juste
avant le le la mise en place du
confinement
vous avez à peu près une semaine
d'incubation vous commencé à être malade
vous êtes éventuellement moins bien et
c'est à partir de ce moment là que vous
allez vous vous adressez à l'hôpital
être adressées à l'hôpital et vous
retrouver soit en hospitalisation
classique soit en réanimation
si votre situation l'exigent et donc
quinze jours après cette contamination
on observe le passage notamment en
réanimation
c'est l'impact de l'épidémie mais c'est
aussi le reflet de cette fameuse
évolutions que nous devrions voir d'ici
la fin de la semaine qui est liée au
fait que le confinement devrait réduire
considérablement le nombre de contacts
parce que nous n'avons pas confiné pour
confiner
l'objectif du confinement ces deux
massivement réduire les contacts entre
les personnes c'est pour ça que même
quand on sort on vous demande parce que
vous travaillez par exemple ou parce que
vous allez faire une course est très
attentif aux gestes barrières et à la
distanciation sociale parce que votre
objectif
notre objectif à tous tous les jours
c'est d'avoir le moins de contacts
possibles et donc si on réduit les
contacts le virus n'arrive plus à passer
d'une personne à l'autre et le nombre de
personnes contaminées doit baisser donc
c'est ce qu'on observe à partir de cette
fin de semaine on devrait avoir moins de
personnes qui arrivent à l'hôpital et
qui arrivent notamment en réanimation
une question pour tf1 y at il une baisse
en ile-de-france d'admis en réanimation
est ce que les chiffres de l'italie nous
apprend quelque chose concernant la
situation en france
alors on est on est pas du tout sur une
baisse actuellement on est en pleine
épidémie d'extension rapide on nous ait
encore dit que le nombre de malades
graves avaient augmenté de 9%
ce qu'on observe que l'on espère c'est
que cette augmentation soit de plus en
plus modestes aux fils a au fil des
jours
parce qu'il faut pouvoir accueillir ses
patients dans des bonnes conditions il
faut des lits de réanimation et vous
savez que les séjours en réanimation
pour des infections graves des malades
qu'ovide c'est souvent des séjours de
deux semaines voir
par semaine donc il ya un enjeu de
capacité de prise en charge et de prise
en charge optimale des patients nous
sommes pas du tout aujourd'hui sur une
sortie de confinement nous sommes déjà à
quelques jours d'une capacité d'évaluer
l'impact du confinement
les italiens nous rapporte et publie des
données sur une relève d'une relative à
relatif ralentissement de l'épidémie les
les français doivent bien comprendre
aussi que le chiffre de décès qui est
toujours très impressionnant reflète
finalement décontamination est une
histoire assez longue
une décontamination qui sont survenus il
ya plusieurs semaines et donc c'est
pourquoi nous allons nous focaliser sur
cette cinétique de l'épidémie et sur ces
personnes qui vont être hospitalisées et
qui auront besoin de réanimation estion
pour france 2 envoyé spécial
caen a été passée la première commande
publique de masques ffp2 depuis le début
de l'épidémie en janvier et en quelle
quantité
pourquoi avoir refusé l'aide des labos
de ville privée de recherche et
vétérinaire pour effectuer davantage de
tests alors premièrement sur les masques
nous allons donner tout l'historique des
masques donc je ne veux pas vous donner
les dates de commandes sur d'autant que
le stock stratégique et piloté par santé
publique france mais il y a un suivi des
stocks stratégiques par santé publique
france une doctrine de masques qui a été
validé au fil des ans sur les types de
masques qui devait être stockées et je
vous rappelle que les établissements de
santé en particulier ont leurs propres
stocks de masques en particulier masques
ffp2 puisque ils les utilisent au
quotidien pour de nombreuses indications
que ce soit en laboratoire ou ce soir
pour prendre en charge des patients
tuberculeux donc on a à la fois 7,7
enjeux de protection par les masques
chirurgicaux de stocks stratégiques
d'une part et puis de stock des
établissements de santé pour les tests
c'est important il faut rappeler que le
texte n'existait pas c'est important de
rappeler puisque nous l'avons mis en
place grâce au soutien d'un situe pas
steurs par définition sur un virus
émergents le test n'existait pas et il a
fallu le mettre au point le test
aujourd'hui c'est important de le
rappeler aussi il passe par un examen
compliqué qui s'appelle une pcr c'est à
dire qu'il faut aller rechercher le
virus dans votre prélèvement qui doit
d'ailleurs être un prélèvement bien
effectué c'est pas un exemple éléments
très agréable normalement l'écouvillon
doit vraiment être enfoncé très loin
dans le caveau hommes et donc c'est un
examen assez désagréable pour la
personne qui
subi on va vraiment frotter votre
muqueuses et aller rechercher le virus
dans cette muqueuse par un examen qui se
faire dans un laboratoire de virologie
au départ c'est là ces examens de
laboratoires devaient être validées par
le centre national de référence pour
être sûr qu'il n'y avait pas de faux
négatifs et que donc tous les
laboratoires qui était agréé savait
faire ce test
ça s'est fait très vite puisque vous
avez vu que nous avons augmenté très
vite le nombre de laboratoires capables
de faire ce test est bien entendu les
laboratoires de villes peuvent faire ce
test
la difficulté actuelle n est pas lié à
la capacité des laboratoires des villes
de faire le test mais à la complexité de
réaliser ce test aujourd'hui puisqu'il
faut tenir compte du fait que nous
sommes confinés que nous demandons aux
gens de ne pas se déplacer de ne pas
être contagieux et de ne pas aller dans
un laboratoire où se trouvent des
personnes fragiles donc c'est cette
structure cette organisation
particulière qui a fait que nous avons
ralenti sur l'accès au laboratoire de
ville mais vous pouvez quand même noter
que soient les derniers chiffres que je
vous ai donné il ya quand même 24 1764
tests qui sont remontés par les
laboratoires de ville donc on voit bien
qu'ils ont une part très importante dans
l'activité qu'ils ont d'ailleurs un taux
de positivité important donc aujourd'hui
on peut avoir accès à ces tests
nous augmentons la capacité de test mais
ce sont des tests qui sont encore assez
compliqué il y aura probablement une
nouvelle génération de tests de
recherche de virus qui va arriver là
encore la recherche et le développement
sont en pleine action donc ce sont deux
problèmes en des tests plus facile comme
on le camp les connaît dans d'autres
pathologies qu'on connaît le trod engine
on connaît un certain nombre de tests
rapides
l'idée d'aller vers ce type de test qui
recherchent le virus et puis il y aura
encore d'autres types de tests on
appelle des sérologies qui sont en cours
de mise au point dans le monde entier et
qui ont un autre objectif non pas de
chercher le virus mais de rechercher des
anticorps et donc de vous dire que vous
avez été en contact avec le virus dans
le passé dans les semaines précédentes
et que vous êtes immunisés une question
pour actusoins des tests sérologiques
pourrez vous pour évaluer pardon les
mobilisations face au co vite 19 existe
à l'international pourquoi ne les
utilise ton pas en france notamment près
des soignantes très exposé alors il
commence
ils commencent à apparaître et la france
va évidemment se doter très rapidement
de ses capacités
de test il faut quand même savoir une
chose premièrement la recherche des deux
tests sérologiques se fait par un
prélèvement sanguin n'est pas sur un
prélèvement respect d'une muqueuses
respiratoires par un coton de séjourner
sur un prélèvement sanguin
c'est un autre type de tête il faut
avoir accès un prélèvement sanguin ou un
au moins à une certaine quantité de sang
ensuite ça n'a d'intérêt que pour des
personnes pour lesquelles on recherche
une séropositivité c'est à dire une
présence dans picot est donc ce n'est
pas pour détecter un patient ou un
soignant positif mais bien pour détecter
une protection chez quelqu'un qui a été
malade et qui a donc confirmation que
ayant été malades
il est désormais immunisé dont vous
voyez que la stratégie est un peu
différent ce n'est pas forcément utile
en pleine épidémie quand les gens sont
malades
c'est potentiellement utiles après pour
savoir qui a fait l'infection et qui ne
l'a pas fait pour europe 1 at on une
idée du nombre de patients admis en
réanimation ou hospitalisées suite à de
l'automédication notamment avec du
plaqué nil alors cette enquête que nous
menons que nous menons d'ailleurs pour
tous les médicaments donc dès qu'une
personne est hospitalisée et en
particulier en réanimation pour un
effets secondaires des médicaments
nous demandons à ce que les médecins
hospitaliers mais c'est valable aussi
pour les médecins de ville signale
immédiatement un effet secondaire grave
de tout médicament
ça peut être un médicament pris de façon
chronique ça peut être une erreur de
posologie ça peut être une
automédication ça peut être à nouveau
traitement et donc nous encourageons à
la fois les médecins et les patients à
signaler tout effet secondaire grave
d'un médicament
nous en avons besoin pour les faire
remonter au centre de pharmacovigilance
pour les faire remonter à l' agence
nationale de sécurité du médicament et
c'est avec ces éléments là que nous
pouvons définir la balance bénéfice
risque d'un médicament
ce qu'il peut apporter mais aussi quels
sont les risques liés à son utilisation
de la pms que l'on confirme des cas de
décès de patients hospitalisés pour kobe
19 liées à des accidents cardiaques dus
à la prise de plaquer nil et si oui
combien
combien de patients prennent du plaqué
niort essais cliniques
alors combien de patients prennent du
plaqué par essais cliniques il ya déjà
je le rappelle tous les patients qui ont
besoin de ce traitement pour des
pathologies chroniques et pour lesquels
nous devons garantir l'accès aux
traitements
le nombre de patients qui s'auto mais
dit que c'est beau
plus difficile puisque normalement on ne
devrait pas avoir accès à
l'automédication pour ce type de
médicament qui peut être toxique seul ou
associé à d'autres médicaments qui
accroît son sa toxicité et donc le
nombre de d'effets secondaires graves
cardiaque est encore plus compliquée a
estimé puisque vous le savez que nous
quand on est en réanimation on peut
avoir une défaillance cardiaque
les causes sont multiples et donc cet or
est animateur lui-même à qui nous
demandons d'estimer si oui ou non il
peut y avoir une imputabilité attribué à
un médicament en particulier à celui ci
met à tout autre médicament puisqu'il a
à ce moment là le devoir de signaler et
de faire ce qu'on appelle un rapport de
pharmacovigilance pour signaler un effet
secondaire potentiel d'un médicament
une question pour hospimedia l'âge
médian des patients est passé de 60 à 58
ans en réanimation
cette diminution est elle la conséquence
d'un prix des admissions en fonction de
l'âge alors franchement je ne crois pas
qu'on fasse de tri à l'admission et
toutes les équipes de réanimation ils
sont vraiment très attentive par contre
ce qu'on observe c'est que il y à des
circuits un peu différent il y à des
organisations différentes
il y à de nombreux établissements
d'accueil des personnes âgées qui se
sont organisés pour prendre en charge
les personnes âgées sur place ou pour
prendre en charge les personnes âgées
avec l'hôpital de proximité ou avec des
unités spécialisées de soins de suite
par exemple spécialisé en en rééducation
respiratoire
ça s'est organisée il ya des structures
de l'hospitalisation en médecine
qu'ovide qui se sont structurés et donc
les personnes qui pouvaient aller en
réanimation avant pas forcément parce
qu'ils étaient graves mais parce qu'on
voulait les surveiller par exemple en
soins intensifs ou en soins continus
peuvent être orientés vers d'autres
structures
ce n'est pas du tri classique de
patients uniquement sur sur un tracteur
d'âge puisque ce n'est pas comme ça
comme un animateur
prend en compte un malade c'est sur son
état clinique sur son pronostic est sur
son besoin ou non de réanimation et
c'est une
c'est une décision qu'il prend de façon
collégiale et qu'il prend tous les jours
de l'année
par contre ce qu'on observe et ça c'est
aussi important parce que c'est observer
à l'international c'est que lorsque
l'épidémie s'étend était le cas
actuellement
on a souvent d'abord dans les premiers
jours les malades les plus fragiles et
plus âgés qui sont ceux qui résistent le
moins au virus et donc qu'il se présente
à l'hôpital
et puis un peu plus tard et ça a été
décrit aussi par nos collègues européens
l'arrivée de jeunes qui ont voulu rester
à la maison longtemps et qu'ils se
rendent compte qu'ils n'arrivent plus à
tenir parce qu'ils font des
complications notamment respiratoires et
qu'ils sont essoufflés et donc ces
personnes là qui peuvent arriver un peu
plus tard en réanimation une question
pour france info où en sont les stocks
de produits anesthésiants dans les
hôpitaux notamment les curares et
notamment en ile-de-france alors vous
avez noté que nous avons une
augmentation très importante du nombre
de malades en réanimation que nous avons
une augmentation très importante du
nombre de lits de réanimation et donc
nous avons une augmentation très
importante des besoins liés à
l'environnement du patient parce que ce
n'est pas uniquement une équipe première
la première condition évidemment majeur
ce n'est pas uniquement des équipements
lourds c'est tout le reste tout ce que
je
j'essaie de vous expliquer parce que
c'est difficile de s'imaginer un lit de
réanimation ou une chambre de
réanimation
il ya une surveillance continue il ya
des prélèvements continue il ya des
traitements continus et il faut parfois
organisé un coma artificiel parce que le
patient a tellement de soins qu'il vaut
mieux qu'ils soient endormis pour éviter
qu'ils soient douloureux par exemple ou
qui luttent contre la machine qui le qui
l'aident à respirer et donc ces
médicaments anesthésiants curare et
autres traitements plutôt classique
d'anésthésie qui sont actuellement
fortement demandés par les réanimateurs
et nous tous sommes attentifs à ce que
toute cette chaîne de prise en charge de
l'animation soit assuré que ce soit le
soutien rh le renfort en équipement est
évidemment l'accès à tous les
médicaments utiles en réanimation
question pour le généraliste des
généralistes crème des retards de soins
chez les chez des patients chroniques
qui n'osent pas venir dans les cabinets
es tu as une erreur de limiter les
sorties aux soins urgents non parce que
nous avons toujours dit depuis le début
que tous les patients qui avaient besoin
de soins devait bénéficier de ce soin je
les dis pour les tout petits qui ont
besoin des vaccinations obligatoires
je les dis pour les femmes qui ont
besoin souvent d'avoir accès à la pmi
qui ont besoin d'avoir accès au planning
familial qui ont besoin d'avoir accès à
liv et j'ai et je les dis évidemment
pour les patients chroniques qui doivent
continuer à être suivi c'est valable
pour toutes les personnes qui sont
dialysés pour les personnes qui ont des
pathologies lourdes qui doivent être
suivis en milieu hospitalier qui doivent
avoir un suivi par un médecin spécialisé
donc ce sont des dérogations évidente de
du confinement vous avez vous êtes
convoqué à l'hôpital vous êtes convoqué
par votre médecin vous avez un suivi
obstétrical évidemment qu'il faut
continuer à être suivis parce que c'est
important pour votre santé
une question pour ses news avez vous
observé des récidives je sais certains
malades
pourquoi on tarde à donner de la
chloroquine alors que certains mettent
semprun de même et le prescrivent à
leurs patients alors récidive pas ma
connaissance on n'a pas de remonter
scientifiques dans ce domaine
quant à l'est de roxy chloroquine on en
parle régulièrement c'est dans l'essai
en cours il ya plusieurs essais
thérapeutiques en cours
précoce ou pas précoce il ya même des
volontés de 2,2 préventif donc tout ce
qui ce tout ce qui peut être utile à la
production de données connaissance de
données scientifiques et de bd 2 de
production de connaissances et est
important il n'y a pas aujourd'hui de
d'indications affaires de
l'automédication encore moins sans
raison parce que là vraiment aussi c'est
juste en prophylaxie ce n'est vraiment
pas une bonne idée est donc vraiment on
voit bien qu'on va très vite qu'on
pousse la recherche
on va avoir des résultats très vite mais
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas d'argument et
c'est pas des données françaises ce
n'est pas la position ennemie tard la
santé c'est la position des experts
internationaux des l'union européenne
des chinois eux-mêmes et de des
autorités américaines qui disent il n'y
a pas d'argument définitif en faveur
d'un médicament plutôt qu'un autre
évidemment regrettable mais c'est comme
ça aujourd'hui aucun médicament au monde
n'a fait la preuve de son efficacité
je peux vous garantir que les autorités
françaises si elle avait la preuve qu'un
médicament est efficace elle ferait en
sorte que les français y aient accès
donc il faut laisser un tout petit peu
de temps à la science pour dire
oui ou non parce qu'on peut aussi avoir
de mauvaises surprises un médicament
permet de modifier le pronostic d'une
infection comme celle du courant d'un
virus une question pour canal+ lorsqu on
devra aborder la fin du confinement est
ce que celle ci est liée à notre
capacité à tester la population si oui
notre capacité en test devrait être de
150 mille tests par jour en juin
est ce suffisant pour envisager un
déconfinement alors c'est pas c'est pas
du tout sur ce type d'argument que ce
passera le déconfinement d'abord vous le
savez c'est une étape ultérieure et nous
ne sommes pas là puisque nous sommes
justes même pas au bout de la deuxième
semaine de confinement que le premier
ministre a déjà confirmé la prolongation
et que nous n'avons même pas encore
d'indicateurs d'évaluation de l'impact
de ce confinement mais je pense que la
sortie du confinement doit être fait de
façon extrêmement attentive
basé sur un une expertise scientifique
qui va évaluer la situation d'épidémie à
ce moment là quelle est la situation
d'épidémie qu'est ce que ça a donné en
termes d' infections graves en terme d'
infections et nécessitant une
hospitalisation au terme d'un fiction en
ville quel est le taux de positivité
combien de cas sont estimés en france
tous ces éléments vont être évidemment
important quels sont les moyens que l'on
se donne en terme de protection de la
population
quel est le niveau d'immunité donc on
voit bien qu'aujourd'hui on n'est pas
capable de répondre à toutes ces
questions parce que là encore nos
connaissances évoluent de jour en jour
l'accès à la recherche et à l'innovation
évolue de jour en jour ce que nous avons
aujourd'hui comme information nous ne
l'avions pas il ya quinze jours et
encore moins ya un mois donc je pense
qu'il faut faire confiance à la
mobilisation totale de nos scientifiques
en france en europe et dans le monde
pour avoir encore plus d'armes pour
lutter contre ce virus
lorsque ce ne se posera la question de
la levée du confinement une question
pour vl médias face à l'afflux de
patients malades du cobp et 19 en
réanimation
quelles mesures ont été prises par la
dgs pour la montée en capacité des
services de rééducation post réanimation
êtes vous confiant dans la capacité des
srp air à faire face dans la durée alors
ce n'est pas que la dgs c'est bien sûr
une mobilisation complète de la
direction générale de la santé de la
direction générale de l'offre de soins
de la direction générale de la cohésion
sociale puisque on voit bien qu'à des
enjeux aussi
d'institutions et d pad et puis de
toutes les agences régionales de santé
qui se mobilisent avec tous les
responsables d'établissements pour
mettre en place un circuit et vous
l'avez présentée d'une certaine façon
j'aurais pu présenter d'une autre façon
on peut décider de rester en institution
avec un soutien médical avec un soutien
hospitalier avec l'intervention d'une
équipe mobile
on peut décider d'aller à l'hôpital de
proximité
on peut décider d'être d'emblée dans un
service de rééducation
on a juste besoin d'avoir un peu de soin
d'avoir de la surveillance d'avoir de la
kiné respiratoire par exemple on peut
rester en milieu hospitalier avec une
surveillance continue à proximité on
peut se retrouver en réanimation et
ensuite sortir de réanimation mais il
faut bien que les françaises et les
français sachent que quand on sort de
réanimation n'est pas debout tout de
suite il faut vraiment une prise en
charge spécialisée pour revenir à la
normale et donc tout ce circuit se met
en place
c'est un travail gigantesque ça sera des
milliers de patients qui vont b devoir
bénéficier de cette prise en charge
spécialisée et elle est déjà en cours
d'organisation puisque heureusement de
plus en plus de patients sortent de
réanimation aujourd'hui certains plutôt
en bonne forme clinique est tant mieux
d'autres ont besoin d'une aide pour
revenir à la maison et donc à chaque
fois c'est une prise en charge
individuelle mais c'est une prise en
charge optimale selon les besoins des
patients
question de cnn le professeur sall au
moins a annoncé samedi la mise à
disposition de tests sérologiques dès
qu'ils seront développés or une
entreprise strasbourgeoise
biosynex annonce est déjà la semaine
dernière en avoir développé seront ils
mis à disposition et si oui quand alors
là aussi je vous disais la recherche et
développement et foisonnante et tant
mieux
nous avons des bons scientifiques en
france nous avons des bons scientifiques
en europe nous avons des bons
scientifiques dans le monde
nous serons attentifs à toutes les
innovations nous avons mis en place avec
le ministère de l'enseignement supérieur
et de la recherche et de l'innovation
des cellules d' analyse de toutes les
innovations et donc évidemment toutes
les innovations sont les bienvenus il
faudra être attentif à la sécurité à la
fiabilité de ces tests normal parce que
les français veulent de la qualité c'est
important et donc nous aurons à la fois
cette analyse en termes de qualité de
disponibilité et de capacité
à répondre aux besoins des français
c'était la dernière question jean
lassalle